director angley's Gemini man has been
screened for critics and it blew their
faces right off just when you thought
movie magic had reached its pinnacle
critics are calling it a new landmark in
visual effects based on the movie's plot
about a hired killer who's stalked by a
younger clone of himself observers have
been quick to draw comparisons between
Gemini man and another recent flick the
name of which escapes us just kidding
it's Ryan Johnson's 2012 film looper
which sports a similar premise but
Gemini man has actually been in
development for over 20 years the first
script for the film was completed in
1997 and at that time it was to be
directed by the late Top Gun director
Tony Scott originally the idea was to
have different actors play the older and
younger versions of main character like
they did in looper
but once producers decided to have the
same actor play both parts the wait for
technology to catch up began well that
technology is finally here and director
Ang Lee goes hog wild using cutting-edge
motion capture technology to render the
younger version of Smith I play both 50
year-old Henry and 23 year-old jr. who's
Santa killing and Lee also shot the film
at 120 frames per second rather than the
typical 24 in order to give it a sense
of visceral realism the result according
to virtually every critic who has been
lucky enough to feast their eyes on the
movie is nothing short of mind-blowing
common thread among the remarks this is
the first coming year is that you will
definitely absolutely positively have to
see a 3d Engadget editor Devendra
hardiwar positively gushed over the film
in a series of tweets vibrating from
excitement after seeing gemini man it
uses 120 fps and 3d to create some of
the most exciting action sequences i've
seen in years
happy to see angley return to action
choreography feels intense because it
looks so realistic he added the script
is a bit generic but I think the visuals
and Smith's performance overcomes it in
terms of groundbreaking visual
experiments this feels as important as
avatar that's a very bold statement but
other critics agree the Gemini man is
arguably the first film since avatar
that requires you to see it in 3d to
really get the full experience sci-fi
feature editor Jordan saccharine said
just saw the final cut of angley's
Gemini man
and it's probably the only movie I'd
ever say must be seen in 3d and 4k if
possible I've never seen anything like
it it felt like I was inside the movie
the sentiment was echoed by refinery29
senior editor and Cohen who wrote just a
Gemini man and it's wild the young
version of Will Smith is incredible plus
some truly beautiful action sequences
and a really great performance by Mary
Elizabeth Winstead the only 3d movie
I'll ever endorse Fandango managing
editor Eric Davis agreed that it needed
to be seen in 3d and also highlighted
how much detail went into making the
film there's one scene in Gemini man
where old Smith and young Smith have an
all-out brawl with each other it's
pretty amazing to watch
I asked Angley how they executed that
sequence and he said it was so involved
it took nine months to complete nine
months for a fight scene meanwhile Yahoo
entertainments senior writer
Ethan alter focused on the film's
groundbreaking juice of a super high
frame rate even high frame rate skeptics
may be converted by what Angley pulls
off in Gemini man while it's not
seamless it's probably the strongest
argument for HFR photography I've seen
and the illusion actually gets better as
the movie goes along the lovefest was
perhaps summed up best by comingsoon.net
senior editor max ER angley's gemini man
is a huge breakthrough for 120fps
presentation action sequences are
breathtaking in this format Will Smith's
winning performance shows a level of
scrutiny a real movie star can stand up
to if you don't see it in theaters
you're missing a true experience
[Music]
crazy all the praise on the film's
technical details is fantastic but it's
colliders Vinnie Mancuso who really cuts
to the chase and tells you what you
truly need to know in gym and I'm an the
young Will Smith throws out not one but
two motorcycles at the old Will Smith
and that to me is very good highly
recommend okay we're sold we'll see you
in line with Gemini man hits the big
screen on October 11 check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]